hi everyone it's Jerry I've recently
been going through some chest puzzles
and I'd like to share 5 of them with you
I know that in many chess books when a
puzzle is given it comes with the
statement such as white to play and
checkmate and so many number of moves or
whites play and win where white would
ultimately be winning material and
consequently the game I'll state it as
this in each of these puzzles it'll be
white to play and it's up to you to
determine what the best continuation is
so it may lead to may it may lead to the
win of material but that's up to you to
determine and let's see how well you can
do with these whoever goes 5 for 5 well
I really don't have anything for you
beyond just a virtual pat on the back
but really if you're looking to improve
your own game this might be something to
take fairly seriously so go ahead pause
the video see if you can find the best
play for white okay the solution to
puzzle one is Knight g6 very forcing
continuation giving check to the black
King and there's only one legal response
since this pawn is pinned King g8 is the
only move and now the continuation Queen
g7 delivering Czech forces of very well
there's only one response rook takes
Queen and now a nice finished Knight h6
two knights in proximity to the black
King this actually delivers checkmate
all the runaway points are guarded by
the white knights
so that's puzzle one the second puzzle
coming up go ahead pause the video if
you like and see if you can find the
solution to this one okay the solution
is first wrote to d8 as was the case in
the first puzzle a very forcing move
there is only one legal response and
that is to just grab the rook and now
this might have been the the difficult
thing to have foreseen and that is the
follow up Queen to b8 offering the Queen
this is one of those Queen sacrifices
where it lures the black King away from
the defense of the d8 rook and so after
rook takes rook that's mate so actually
these first two puzzles that I just show
that I just showed you where checkmate
in three problems so moving on to the
third one
let's see what we have third one right
here once again white to move go ahead
pause the video see if you can find the
result to this one okay move one is
actually this very stunning move Queen
to a7 check in we have the following
sequence of moves King takes Queen
that's the only response rook takes pawn
giving check King in the corner is the
only move Knight b6 check King b8 once
again all forest and this is actually
probably one of the more difficult moves
to see and that is rook on D to d7 so
one of these quiet type of moves there
you know there wasn't any capture made
or any check delivered with this last
move rook D to d7 however the threat of
just moving the rook to b7 to give
checkmate is unavoidable unavoidable at
least for just one move the only way to
delay checkmate would be Queen h4 but
after pawn takes Queen there's no way to
avoid rook to b7 on the next move to
deliver checkmate so that was probably
one of the more difficult puzzles thus
far moving on to the fourth one this is
the position we have again pause the
video see if you can find the answer
okay the solution to this one is rook on
D to F 1 this is the best continuation
it's attacking this Queen on f7 and she
doesn't have very many choices if for
example she were to play to be 8 that
would run into rook takes rook check
Queen takes rook Knight g6 mate this is
a common idea that you have to be aware
of in this position taking into account
that this pawn is pinned along the H
file so that's that's just one what if
you know if the Queen went to d8 that's
what would occur
what about Queen to e7 well that's just
going to run into checkmate in one at
that point this will be mate since the
week the White Queen covers g8 and one
other continuation is well after rook on
D to F one after Queen takes Queen now
we have this nice sequence of moves
Knight g6 forcing King g8 97
King h8 followed by rook takes h7 check
bringing the king out and now we have
rook on well the rook moving just to h1
and this is mate
the knight conveniently covers both g8
and g6 this is mate so one more puzzle
to go puzzle 5 so have any of you gone
for 4 4 at this point be sure to let me
know in the comments if you go 5 4 5 so
this is the last puzzle let's see if you
can find the solution to this one ok the
first move for white is Knight to g5 one
of these quiet type of moves in the
sense that it's not again delivering
Czech or capturing a piece but a very
very serious threat is in mind with this
Knight g5 move starting just to crash
through on this h7 point really the only
serious variation to consider is what
would occur after Bishop takes Queen
that would result in just rook takes
pawn check and after Queen takes rook a
really nice final move Knight takes rook
and that's checkmate so even being down
a queen white ends up just winning by
way of us one of those smothered
checkmates so be sure to let me know how
you did if any of you went 5 for 5 I
think that's pretty good so let me know
if I a comment and also let me know what
won which one of these 5 puzzles you
thought was the most difficult ok that's
all for now take care bye